-Non, recule !
-Bonjour.
Merci à vous d'être venu.
On vient regarder notamment
vos infrastructures.
Il y a un projet
de rénovation des vestiaires
qui, je pense, n'est pas du luxe.
-12 dans un truc comme ça...
On va aux cèpes.
Chez nous,
c'est la région, donc voilà,
on va aux champignons,
pas au foot.
-Entre les bactéries
qui se développent,
les douches qui sont pas saines,
les radiateurs à l'ancienne
qui peuvent mettre le feu...
-Le point de non-retour.
-A vous de jouer,
messieurs les élus.
-Bonjour,
*Julien Rancoule,
député de la 3e circo de l'Aude.
Je suis en quelque sorte
un enfant du pays.
J'ai grandi dans cette ruralité
et je fais une proposition
visant à créer
un fonds d'investissement
pour les communes
de moins de 3500 habitants,
qui rencontrent des difficultés
*pour réaliser
les investissements nécessaires.
Je vais vous amener avec moi
rencontrer les maires
pour qu'ils expliquent
leurs difficultés.
-A Espéraza,
à 20 km au sud de Limoux,
dans la haute vallée de l'Aude,
le maire voudrait
rénover les vestiaires
de son stade.
Il a convié le député.
-Ils se changent là,
les joueurs ?
-Après, c'est surtout
dans les vestiaires où...
-L'hiver, ils doivent pas
se régaler.
Vous avez de la moisissure
au plafond...
-Moi, je vous dis,
on y jouait dans les années 80,
c'était strictement pareil. Il n'y
a rien qui a été refait.
-Au niveau de l'hygiène,
c'est pas top.
-Là, voilà les douches.
L'électricité passe au-dessus.
Il n'y a rien pour aérer, donc,
voilà.
-Ouais, l'humidité...
-Il y a tout qui se casse la figure.
-Les champignons, voilà.
-Les mycoses...
-Les mycoses,
c'est fabuleux.
-Les plaques que tu vois dessus...
-Les plaques d'isolation ?
-Ce sont
des plaques d'isolation Défisol,
c'est du polyuréthane expansé
et c'est un produit cancérigène.
On va casser les blocs
et on va les refaire propres.
-Reste maintenant à trouver
les 80 000 euros nécessaires
pour les travaux,
car le maire n'a plus les moyens.
La commune est étranglée
par l'inflation.
Jusqu'à présent,
elle payait 30 000 euros
de gaz et d'électricité par an.
-On passe donc sur les factures
qui explosent.
Donc, tu le sais aussi bien que moi,
sur les petites communes,
c'est très, très compliqué.
-En plus, à quelques mois
d'intervalle, je vois.
Là, c'est fin d'année 2022,
par rapport à janvier 2023...
-On a été impactés directement,
sur une hausse
de 19 à 200 000 euros.
-Oui, c'est de la folie.
-Multiplié par 11 sur le gaz.
-Tu t'es renseigné
pour voir si t'as droit
à quelque chose, un abattement ?
-Oui, on a droit à rien.
On a droit à rien,
ni amortisseur, ni bouclier.
Si la commune met
entre 300 000 ou 400 000 euros
dans les fluides,
dans 2 ans, 3 ans,
je sais pas comment
je vais payer les employés.
Voilà.
Alors, tenable ? Non.
-Christian Soula a déjà dû couper
le chauffage
des salles de sa commune.
Il a stoppé tous ses projets.
La situation
inquiète le député.
-C'est la mort à petit feu
de la ruralité.
Elles ne peuvent plus...
Elles rentrent tout juste
dans leur budget pour assurer
les dépenses de fonctionnement.
Et donc, elles ne peuvent
plus assurer les dépenses,
les investissements indispensables
pour leur commune.
-Alors, Julien Rancoule a déposé
une proposition
de loi : il veut créer
un fonds de revitalisation
de 400 millions d'euros
pour ces communes rurales.
Une aide supplémentaire
versée par l'Etat
pour financer leurs projets.
-On se sent assez abandonnés
par les pouvoirs publics, ici,
vraiment abandonnés, et donc,
en tant que député,
j'essaie justement d'alerter
le gouvernement
sur la situation, de proposer
des solutions à cette situation,
notamment par la création
de ce fonds
pour les petites communes
qui permettrait justement
de revitaliser cette ruralité.
-Sur ces terres
autrefois de gauche,
la défense du territoire
dépasse la couleur politique.
A Brousses-et-Villaret,
le maire cherche des fonds
pour restaurer ces 2 églises.
Depuis 1905,
elles sont à la charge des communes.
Une charge très lourde
pour les villages.
-On doit refaire
tous les enduits extérieurs,
toutes les menuiseries,
les fenêtres, les vitraux.
Les soubassements
étaient en amiante,
donc on a désamianté.
Il y a du bois...
Il faut vraiment tout reprendre,
y a de la pierre,
du ciment vraiment très dur,
qui n'a rien à faire là.
Donc il y a vraiment un gros travail
de restauration à reprendre.
Pour vous montrer vraiment
dans quel état
se trouvent les vitraux
de l'église Saint-Etienne,
on les a même bouchés
avec du papier bulle
pour éviter que les bestioles
et que le froid rentrent.
C'est quand même dans un état
très, très délabré.
Il faut les changer
et les refaire de A à Z
et c'est ce qui coûte, ça aussi,
très cher.
-C'est de notre responsabilité
et de la responsabilité de l'Etat.
-Il faut surtout pas que l'Etat
oublie son patrimoine, quoi, voilà.
-Pour eux, pas question
de désacraliser
et de vendre cette église,
même si elle ne sert
qu'occasionnellement.
-C'est le patrimoine rural,
c'est la ruralité, c'est la France.
-Et se rattacher à un patrimoine,
à une histoire, à une culture,
à des traditions, ça nous permet
encore d'avoir un esprit d'équipe,
un esprit de village,
et c'est essentiel, ici.
-Cela a un coût : rien
que sur cette église,
ces travaux sont estimés
à 100 000 euros,
et aujourd'hui, les subventions
ne couvrent qu'une petite partie
de la facture.
-On peut espérer 25 %.
30, on n'y arrivera pas.
Donc, même sur 100 000 euros,
il reste quand même
une somme énorme.
Il faut sortir encore
60 000 euros.
Avec un budget à 400 000 euros,
on passe pas.
On peut pas se permettre de mettre
60 000 euros sur 400 000
dans la rénovation
d'une seule tranche de l'église.
Voilà, c'est pour ça qu'on compte
vraiment beaucoup sur ce projet.
-Les aides du département,
de la région
et les dotations
ne suffisent plus.
Face à l'inflation,
ces maires ruraux
veulent que l'Etat
les aide davantage.
Musique douce
...
Gincla,
au coeur du pays cathare,
46 habitants à l'année.
Ici, faute de moyens,
le maire et son frère entretiennent
eux-mêmes le village.
-Là, on avait eu une rupture
de canalisation,
une canalisation en fonte
qui s'est cassée,
on n'a pas appelé
un plombier.
Le petit frère
a pris sa tractopelle,
et on est allés chercher
le matériel pour réparer.
Ca a été fait dans la journée,
ça a été très rapide.
Personne n'a eu de manque d'eau.
-On touche à la plomberie,
la maçonnerie.
On touche à peu près
tout et c'est vrai que ça permet
de faire beaucoup de travaux
nous-mêmes pour éviter de plonger.
Avec le peu de moyens
que les communes ont...
-Vous faites venir un plombier
pour réparer une canalisation,
vous en avez tout de suite
pour 1500 euros.
Donc sur un budget
de 100 000, 1500, ça compte.
C'est 3 jours ou 4 jours
de vie de la commune,
donc toutes les petites économies
sont importantes.
-Mais pour la chaussée,
il faut bien faire appel
à une entreprise. Julien Rancoule
est venu constater les difficultés
que rencontre
le maire sur ce dossier.
-Le goudronnage
devrait se faire, normalement,
fin mai, début de juin.
Mais bon, vous voyez,
y a des gouffres
partout sur la route.
Si on le fait pas
de suite, ça empire, ça empire,
et là, ça devient catastrophique.
-Rien que pour cette route,
le coût est important,
impossible
à assumer sans aides.
-Là, on est entre 25 000
et 30 000 euros.
Le problème,
c'est qu'on avait demandé
les subventions
il y a trois ans de ça.
Le devis d'il y a deux ans
et demi en arrière,
vu le prix des matières
premières maintenant,
je ne sais pas à quel niveau
on va arriver.
On arrivera
peut-être à 35 000,
auquel cas ce sera 10 000 de plus
pour la commune.
-Parce que les réponses
du département et de la région
ont tardé,
le maire a dû reporter
tous ses autres projets.
-La place de la mairie
est défoncée.
Il était prévu normalement
de la faire cette année,
mais avec le retard
sur les demandes de subventions...
On a deux ans de retard.
Ce sera le projet futur
pour dans deux ans de plus.
Donc pendant deux ans encore,
ça va se dégrader.
On ne peut pas tout faire
à la fois, c'est sûr.
-Sur la commune,
on a beaucoup de voiries,
par rapport
au nombre d'habitants.
Vous avez des hameaux,
de voiries communales.
C'est un poids qui pèse
sur les finances de la commune.
Donc c'est pour ça
qu'on a intégré,
j'ai intégré cet aspect
à ces dépenses-là
dans le fonds
qui n'est aujourd'hui pas couvert
par les subventions d'Etat
existantes.
Musique flâneuse
...
-Sur les plateaux des Pyrénées,
le maire de Rodome, lui,
lutte contre la désertification.
Pour revitaliser
son village isolé,
il rénove les appartements
de la commune.
-Ici, c'est l'ancienne poste,
donc c'est un appartement
qu'on a restauré.
Donc il y a trois chambres,
salle à manger, cuisine.
On remet
en conformité électrique,
l'hygiène, la peinture, etc.
Il faut savoir que là...
-C'est à la charge de la commune.
-Tout.
C'est le deuxième appartement.
On en a quatre.
C'est le deuxième qu'on refait.
Le premier, on en a eu
pour 14 000 euros.
-Un appartement ?
-Oui.
-Celui-ci, pour le moment,
on en est à 8000 euros
et c'est pas fini. Voilà.
-Cet appartement à loyer modéré
sera bientôt
remis en location.
Au total,
ces quatre logements rapportent
18 000 euros par an
au village.
Une rentrée non négligeable,
mais surtout des habitants
à l'année en plus.
-Deux enfants,
ce serait bien.
Un couple et deux enfants.
-OK.
-Voilà, ça ferait marcher
aussi l'épicerie
parce qu'on a une épicerie
à la mairie,
une épicerie communale,
avec le gaz,
du congelé,
des produits locaux.
Moi, c'est mon projet
de faire vivre
le village.
C'est important.
-C'est un combat de tous les jours.
-Exactement.
-L'autre combat,
c'est celui des aides,
entre les aides
à la rénovation,
auxquelles
il n'a pas le droit,
et celles pour lesquelles
il faut déposer
des dossiers complexes.
-Il faut simplifier
les aides,
c'est mon point de vue.
On a l'aide de département,
de l'Etat...
-Région.
-...la région.
C'est hyper compliqué.
Voilà, nous, on est
des petites communes.
Aujourd'hui, les maires,
s'ils n'ont pas de secrétaire,
les maires sont foutus.
-Il y a une complexification.
-Si jamais vous pouvez
simplifier les choses,
ce sera... énorme.
-Un guichet
unique pour regrouper
et simplifier les demandes.
L'idée séduira peut-être
le député.
Il espère déjà
pouvoir défendre
sa proposition de loi à l'Assemblée.
-C'est un choix politique.
L'Etat, pour moi, doit mettre
les moyens dans la ruralité
pour lui permettre de survivre,
mais aussi
d'être plus ambitieuse
et d'être vraiment dans l'avenir,
tout simplement.
-Et comment l'Etat le finance ?
-Encore une fois,
c'est un choix politique.
400 millions d'euros,
c'est assumable par l'Etat.
C'est un choix politique,
on peut...
J'ai parlé de la politique
de la ville.
Je pense
qu'on peut récupérer
une partie des fonds de la politique
de la ville vers la ruralité.
Ca me semble pas
un choix négatif.
-Quitte à raviver
la querelle
entre ville et campagne.
Julien Rancoule va surtout
devoir convaincre les députés
de dépenser plus
pour ces territoires.
Jusqu'à présent,
aucune proposition de loi du RN
n'a été votée.
En France,
90 % des communes
ont moins de 3500 habitants.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA